for some perspective on these and other
developments we turn to Bob Cusack
editor-in-chief of the hill Bob good
morning good morning we are joking
there's always a lot to get to so we
will we will get right to it let's start
there where Jeff was the judge in the
Paul Manafort case he's known for being
combative but certainly came out
sounding like he was very against some
of what the prosecutors were saying
what's the likelihood that we'll see
some of the charges in this indictment
dropped I think it's unlikely you see
the charges drop he's also facing
charges in DC so even that does happen
but this was a rare bit of good news for
the mana for legal team the judge
pressing Muller on do you just want to
get man afford to sing about Trump and
of course Muller's team is saying hey
this is relates to collusion because he
was the campaign manager so a lot more
to go here but without a doubt
Manta Ford has wet not guilty to all the
charges but but I think Muller does want
him to talk well isn't I mean isn't that
somewhat of the idea you obviously want
to get to him so you can learn more here
right right and he's gotten a lot of
people to talk but not Manta for it not
yet yeah I saw a lot of people
celebrating on twitter the hashtag judge
Ellis was trending from people who
support the president but let's talk
about Rudy Giuliani and this media blitz
that he was on over the course of the
last week did Rudy Giuliani harm the
president more than he helped him yeah I
think I think it hurt the president in
the White House because you have this
good economic news that came out
yesterday
you have the possible release of
Americans from North Korea that's a big
deal what are we talking about Rudy
Giuliani he put out a clarifying
statement yesterday really didn't
clarify anything there's a lot more
questions I think he's got a answer more
questions so now the question is whether
he's gonna stop the media blitz because
we didn't still don't know what exactly
happen did the president know about it
whether it was he reimbursed or not so I
think it was a big distraction there's
also a New York Times report that was
saying that the president knew a while
before about the payment before he said
yeah yeah and that's I mean when you
think about it the story to begin with
was not quite believable is that Michael
Cohen just paid for me Danny was kinda
$30,000 out of his own pocket the
president know about and then Giuliani
was saying oh no he didn't know about it
did reimburse and then that's when you
had this whole controversy once again we
ignite and some Trump supporters are
saying why does it all matter why does
it all matter well
doesn't matter to the Trump supporters I
mean they do think this is a witch-hunt
so his base is very strong with him I
think that that Trump could do a lot of
different things even an immigration his
base is gonna stick with him so it
doesn't hurt him with his face but with
independence and certainly it gins up
the Democratic base which is very fired
up for the midterms given the this
president's history wouldn't it be isn't
it not conceivable that he could just
say look this happened I've apologized
to my family let's move on North Korea
economic news and his base as you say
would be sure they would be fine with
that yeah because his base doesn't care
about this story but you know the
president doesn't apologize but you know
it just doesn't do it but that would
make the story go away we would be able
to move on as long so what are the
details what actually happened and the
thing is maybe Mahler already knows
because of the microcon rate of the
financial transactions that was some
that was some people saying okay
Julian's want to get it out there
because he knows Muller knows about
these payment right we don't know that
yet though and as far as the president
sitting down with Robert Muller we sort
of have heard two things we've heard him
say he will but only if he was
guaranteed that this will be fair I
don't know that you could ever guarantee
at least in his mind that it would be
fair what's the likelihood then that we
see and I I don't think is gonna happen
because I thought it was gonna happen
before the micro cone raid but now I
don't think so I think that the legal
team around Trump has even though it's
been shifting a lot and different
members of team have told him don't do
this now Muller could try to subpoena
him in force but that could be a battle
that goes all the way the supreme court
could take months but Muller does want
to interview the president I think
chances are less than 50/50 actually
actually less than 50 less than 50/50
yeah all right let's turn to some
international news Iran do the May 12th
deadline is fast approaching what are
your sources telling you about which way
the president is leaning well certainly
I think that he's not gonna continue the
deal and the question is what happens
with the rest of our allies because
that's where it's important US sanctions
are not enough for Iran to get nervous
about but it's with France and with
Germany and other allies that the
sanctions actually could snap back and
hurt Iran so but I think this is Trump
going back to his campaign promise and
he has been he doesn't like to certify
this deal I don't think he's going to
continue on then the question is what
next right Bob Cusack from the hill
thank
very much to be appreciate it